(Commodore)
You wanted to see me?
This better be important.
I've called you in here
to remind you
that, according to
our marital contract,
I am to fellate you
seven times a year.
I told you, the saltpeter
mines of the Congo
destroyed my sex drive.
I'm so sorry.
- Come here.
- I want you so badly.
Just wanted to feel
close to my husband.
Yes, I feel the same.
Peepers.
I already filled
the syringe, madam.
[sighs]
[moans]
Peepers...
[crying]
I fear that Commodore
is having an affair.
Put the tray over there.
If you want your food,
you're going to have
to come and get it.
No!
Hands and knees.
You're going to crawl.
He called out the name "Celine"
in his sleep.
Sounds French-Canadian.
No!
Ugh.
I move in here
based on the promise
from some pathetic old fool
that it would be
a nice place to keep me close.
Then the bastard disappears.
The thought of him
engaging in sexual congress
with a snow-Negro...
Oh, no.
I'm sorry, darling.
Why don't you show me
just how sorry you are?
Oh...
Yes, my mistress.
[exhales]
You look like you climbed
out of a pile
of dirty underwear.
Leave me alone, troll.
Don't you have a bridge
to guard?
I quit that job.
Too much billy goat shit.
So that's
your scheme, huh?
Feeding your fish
to the Commodore?
It's pretty obvious.
Ugh!
Ah, what are you--
You always did know
how to make me horny.
You say a word,
and you are dead man.
Death don't scare me.
I've saved up 50 cents.
That'll do.
For now.
I'm gonna blackmail
the shit out of her.
[rhythmic creaking]